foreign
let's go to Jackson
I think it's Chanute Kansas Jackson is
that right
yes that is correct that's Chanute
Chanute nailed it yeah it would be cool
if you called it Chanute but it's cool
Chanute it is what's up Jackson yeah hey
how you doing I'm rocking up to the
break of dawn dude do you go by Jack or
Jackson
Jackson listen I have a buddy whose kid
is named Jack that's a dope name
Jackson's cool
but Jack my nephew who's actually just
named Jack too so oh that's cute you
have a like a family member who likes
you
I guess
siblings don't even name their pets
after me but whatever all right so
what's up
um I'm just gonna start off by saying uh
it's kind of nerve-wracking so if you'll
just bear with me
um
so and I'm kind of gonna be all over the
place but my basic question is
um I have a best friend
who's in a relationship and he's wanting
to you know in the near future whether
it's like a month or six months I don't
know the time frame he says he's saving
up a ring to buy to get engaged they
have a promise ring since like two years
ago or so so this has been going on for
a long time and they lived together and
um he's gonna ask me to be his best man
because I was his he was my best man and
it's kind of just like a you know a
known thing between us too we're going
to be each other the best man but if he
goes through with this and he you know
actually
gets engaged and marries this this woman
that he's been with for like five years
I really can't see myself
um like saying yes and and being his
best man because I can't stand by him
while he marries this this person and I
don't know if that's just like is it am
I the issue like am I you know you know
I'm not trying to control him or
anything like that I just I want to see
him Thrive and be the best himself then
this person is not helping him
um and I just I don't know what to do
and I you know some of my friends my
other like our mutual friends they uh
they agree with me and and we're gonna
hopefully talk to him sometime in the
future if that's what we should do
um I just wanted to get your thoughts on
the whole thing
um that's that's kind of where I am cool
well thanks for thanks for verbalizing
it like that and thanks for loving your
friend
um I'm gonna work
I'm gonna go to the very end of this
question and work all the way back okay
okay
um right before this show one of my best
friends in the world called and it's
going to see a counselor brilliant guy
and
uh I recommended a counselor that's like
known to be the best of the best of the
best in this particular city and state
and so my buddy went and met with the
person and they hit it off and then this
person said hey I'm not taking any new
clients but I'll take you on
um I'll we'll figure this out
I'm gonna send you on my price sheet and
you're gonna have sticker shock
and
sticker shock is the understatement very
very expensive wildly expensive and you
got to pay six months all at one like
right and but this is guys world class
and so my friend called me back and was
asking all kinds of like do you think
he's like charging like this and I I
checked up the academic credentials and
I looked at this and I was checking this
oh I mean back
finally I said hey who cares
who cares if this person said I charge
five thousand dollars a session
my first thought would be dude if you
can get it get it man like high five I'm
not paying that and I'm gonna move on to
my with my day right so I told him
you're carrying a lot of existential
angst around trying to figure out why is
this person charged so much and what do
they think they're doing that justifies
this and I don't know if I can afford
this or if I can't afford I don't want
to spend that
dude like I just say like brother you're
carrying a lot of extra weight he put a
price down and I'm gonna say no thanks
have a great day and I'm gonna move on
to my next thing
so
tying that story back to you
have a particular set of values and you
think that he should not be marrying
this person to the point that you've
chosen you've decided I'm not going to
be your best man if he asks me he's
gonna ask me I am I'm gonna say no
and so
there should be a period at the end of
that sentence
because you know it's going to come on
the back end he's been with this person
five years he's not going to magically
go oh my gosh why you didn't you don't
like her and then he's gonna change his
whole life that's not going to be how
that that's not why you're saying no
you're saying no because I can't
participate in this not to try to get
him to change his mind at the last
second
so whatever he does on the back end will
screw you then forget you we're done
like I'm not hanging out with you
anymore you're an idiot that's his
choice you make a grown-up decision he
gets to make a grown-up decision and you
can weep be heartbroken be sad all that
kind of stuff but you can't save your
friend like that if he hasn't invited
you in so I would make my values
decision and stand on my values
now getting a little bit closer to right
now
the part of me like I've got a couple of
close buddies like I've been in their
wedding been like all that stuff
I'm stunned that you haven't sat him
down before now and said bro I can't
stand by this or let me ask you this
question why are you waiting until he
asks you to be his best man
to let him know where you stand that
seems abjectly not cool
yeah I think I agree with that and and
me and my another friend of ours were
working to to kind of sit him down yeah
let me stop you right there what is that
this sounds like somebody I mean you
were he was the best man in your wedding
like I don't know what there is to work
up
like my best friends I call and say dude
what are you doing like that's how the
call starts or hey
I just got this text message from you
you're not all right what's what's the
deal like there's nothing to work up
like we've passed working up that's what
makes them my best man that's what makes
them like like literally my brothers
because I don't have to work up anymore
so what what is that fear that's
in a relationship that I think should be
well past all that stuff
um I think it's because I'm afraid of of
losing him after 10 years of friendship
because I don't like you know I don't
agree with you know the person he's
going to be with and uh I just am afraid
of losing him and him going well you
don't want to decide what I do you've
already left him and I'm Jackson you've
already left him
you left him
and you have every right to do that but
you're already gone
you're hanging on to a myth brother
like you already you've already decided
that when he asks me one of the most
important questions of his life I'm
going to tell him no you're already out
of this relationship
now you're hanging on to a picture of
what could be if he wasn't in this about
to get married to this person he's been
with for five years he's going to and so
reality is sailed on and you're you're
back here
this relationship has already changed
you just haven't had the courage to tell
him it's changed
is that fair
yeah that's that's fair how do I you
know how would I even another thing that
I'm kind of struggling with is how do I
even bring it up you know we never ever
talk about these things he never had a
say in my wedding why should I ever say
at his wedding is like out of the blue
I'm just like hey I don't like this
person you know like what I even where
do I even start like I don't I don't
know where to start
that's a great question so I would start
this way I would be very very clear
I've got friends who like I don't like
like I wouldn't have chosen their wives
to hang out with
but they're not bad people that might be
too loud or too quiet or too weird or
they don't think I'm funny and I'm the
best right jack like like I don't I
don't have they wouldn't have been my
first pick but they're great people
they're good human beings and I don't
mind my kids playing with their kids and
they're great moms they're great
Partners to my friend like so
ask yourself do I just not like them or
here's two or three or five or ten ways
this person is harmful
completely dishonest cheats on you
forces you to do things that are I'm
watching my friend Wither on the fine
you used to be like this and this person
has taken this from you I've watched it
I've had a ringside seat to this so I
would be very very clear about what my
objections to this other person are
and I would so that's that's spending
time with yourself and I wouldn't even
do this with another buddy I would be
very clear about this with myself what
is it that I feel so strongly about that
I can't be involved in this relationship
at all I don't want to be in that
picture that's going to be taken at that
wedding
the second thing is I would sit down
with my friend and if you bring somebody
else to this type of conversation it's
gonna feel interventiony or gang up like
you're ganging up on him I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that
I would
um if I had this kind of relationship I
would tell him hey I failed you brother
because I haven't told you the truth for
a long long time
and I should have told you a long time
ago and I wimped out and then I just got
down the road and so here we are
um
I've watched and that's where you're
gonna have that list I've watched my
friend wither away I've watched my
friend get further and further away from
the guy I've known for 10 years
and I should have called it out a long
time ago and I didn't and I I can't
sleep at night knowing how much I love
you and you're my friend of a decade
without speaking my mind and I know this
might cost our friendship and I hope it
doesn't but this I've got to be honest
and that's how I would do it I would own
the fact that you should have had this
conversation three years ago four years
ago five years ago and you didn't and so
here we are right
and just know your friend is going to
have a incredibly hard Choice Maybe
it may be a very simple choice for him
he may say oh thank God somebody finally
said something or he might say well you
just opted out of my life brother
go on about your day because I'm
marrying her and cool
you know what I mean
yeah
yeah I've ran those scenarios in my head
and I what do you what do you think is
going to happen what are you scared of
it's bigger than you think he's just
gonna walk away from a 10-year
friendship
um I mean that is basically the the
whole thing is as I come up to him and
after five years of not saying something
I'm like hey here's the facts you know
this is how I feel and he goes well then
I don't want you in my life anymore and
I lose you know we we play games
together all the time we're we're
constantly texting each other all the
time we send each other videos funny
videos and our relationship is just so
awesome
Jackson it's not because it's not a real
relationship because you're not being
honest with him
you're not telling the truth and you
haven't for years
so you all might share laughs
and I've got lots of I've got lots of
Associates people I've known for two
decades three decades that I share
laughs with that I text funny pictures
back and forth to that are on long long
text threads
but they don't know when my marriage
goes sideways
they don't know when I screw up as a dad
I got four or five men that I talked to
about that
four or five men one or two women and
those women are connected to those men
like
like there's very very few people I talk
to about that stuff
and whether you believe that or not this
guy isn't that guy because you sat
across from him for five years and kept
a huge secret from him
and so and to preserve that relationship
yeah at some point you come clean some
point you sit down and say dude I should
have told you a long time ago and I'm
sorry I screwed up
um
and I know this is going to alter things
between us and I know you're gonna have
to do what you want to do
but here's what a layout here's what it
is
here's what it is and for everybody
listening I want you to like I'm
intentionally not asking him what the
things are
because I don't want
I don't want all of us having a ringside
seat into that's not even that big a
deal or oh my gosh what
he's got to make his call outside of
like like physical
um or psychological abuse right
um outside of that he's got to make his
own call this is just against my value
against my values and I can't be a part
of this thing but I need you to get out
of the fantasy Jackson that you have
this great killer relationship because
it's not it's built on a house of
dishonesty
and so it's time to come clean
it'll be hard if you have to write it
down write it down but it's it it's time
to come clean
and let's start
building the relationship that you
actually think you have let's be real
with it
and then let the let him make a grown-up
decision let the cards fall as they fall